bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
s'il vous plaît merci de répondre sur le
chat pour savoir si la connexion est
bonne et que mes propos sont audibles
oui merci Johan
ok tout le monde est installé dans les
classes
ok on va commencer donc bonjour je me
présente je suis Sandrine charge je
m'occupe de la communication de la
chambre de métier de l'artisanat je vous
remercie de participer à cette cinquième
édition de la Journée Découverte de
l'apprentissage qui est organisé par la
Chambre de métier de l'artisanat en
partenariat avec
Les Apprentis d'Auteuil à Marcoussis la
Faculté des Métiers à Évry et le CFA de
Brétigny qui concerne les métiers du
bâtiment
les cinq web conférences que nous
proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la Semaine nationale de l'apprentissage
sont consacrés à votre orientation vers
les métiers de l'automobile du goût de
l'esthétisme et de la beauté du bâtiment
et de la fleuristerie
donc c'est souvent des métiers qui font
partie de la famille de l'artisanat
c'est pourquoi nous organisons cette
journée avant de commencer notre web
conférence j'aimerais vous resituer
quelques éléments de contexte par
rapport à au secteur de l'artisanat et à
l'apprentissage
l'artisanat français est un secteur qui
a le vent en poupe en ce moment un
million 800 000 entreprises artisanales
ont été recensées en juin 2022 cela fait
plus de 80 000 entreprises artisanales
de plus par rapport à l'année dernière
donc c'est un c'est un secteur qui est
très dynamique
aujourd'hui un créateur d'entreprise sur
4 va créer son entreprise dans
l'artisanat
quête de sens valorisation du fabriqué
en France et recherche d'épanouissement
personnel et professionnels toutes ces
valeurs poussent vous les jeunes et les
personnes en reconversion
professionnelle vers l'artisanat qui est
un véritable
qui a un nouveau modèle économique
la preuve 178
000 apprend apprentis oui ont été formés
dans l'artisanat en 2020-2021 2020 2021
étant l'année scolaire soit plus de 15%
par rapport à l'année dernière c'est un
record qui n'a encore jamais été égalé
l'apprentissage fait donc partie
intégrante de l'ADN de l'artisanat
sachez que la formation par la voix de
l'apprentissage offre de très belles
perspectives d'avenir
80% des apprentis trouvent un emploi
dans les six mois qui ont suivi la fin
de la formation
et un an un entreprene cinq
entrepreneurs sur dix ouvrent une
entreprise dans le secteur de
l'artisanat
voilà quelques éléments qui peuvent
alimenter votre discussion et peut-être
qu'ils vont
susciter des vocations là dans les
classes
place maintenant à la présentation
des interlucuteurs qui m'entourent alors
Dominique vous êtes responsable de la
responsable ingénierie de la filière
fleuristerie c'est ça
Virginie vous êtes formatrice
formatrice technique formatrice
technique pour quelle classe pour les
CAP fleuristes pour les CAP fleuristes
et j'ai autour de la table deux
apprentis qui font en ce moment leur
cursus en apprentissage au CFA de
Marcoussis Alicia dans quelle classe
es-tu en deuxième année en apprentissage
du point cap
c'est un deuxième année
je peux te demander quel âge as-tu
reprendra peut-être mais il y a une
histoire autour de d'Alicia puisque en
général les jeunes en CAP ils ont
16-17 voilà mais Alicia a une histoire
Matéo tient en quelle classe
donc toi aussi tu as une histoire tu as
changé de voix on en parlera tout à
l'heure
si vous avez des questions
quel que soit la question n'hésitez pas
à la poser il y a un chat dédié pour
cela on relève toutes les questions et
on y répondra à la fin de la
présentation la courte présentation
d'une vingtaine de minutes de ce que
sont les métiers de la fleuristerie
comment
on s'inscrit
tout le cursus qui est dispensé à
Marcoussis je laisse maintenant la
parole
aux deux représentants du CFA qui sont
Dominique et Virginie
rapidement donc la présentation de notre
campus quel campus Saint-Antoine de la
Fondation apprenti d'Auteuil
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes sur une
fondation qui a beaucoup de centres en
France on a 300 centres aujourd'hui qui
sont présents et créés
140 sur la région Île-de-France avec
différentes spécialités et plus
précisément faire un focus sur notre
campus de Marcoussis nous avons un
campus avec aujourd'hui donc trois
quatre grands métiers représentés qui
sont l'horticulture le paysage la
fleuristerie les services à la personne
et on accueille sur notre site 250
élèves
avec en effet des filières en effet en
formation initiale et en formation par
apprentissage
alors peut-être que Virginie peut parler
du métier de fleuriste donc le métier de
fleuriste c'est un métier de l'artisanat
nous à Marcoussis donc on propose une
formation en apprentissage qui est
ouverte aux jeunes dès la fin de la
troisième mais également à des personnes
un peu moins jeunes qui voudraient se
reconvertir mais qui ont quand même
moins de 30 ans pour pouvoir faire un
contrat d'apprentissage
ils sont donc en entreprise on va dire
deux à trois semaines par mois et sur le
campus une ou deux semaines par mois ils
travaillent donc 35 heures par semaine
comme la plupart des employés et ce sont
bien des employés plus des étudiants
du coup
quand ils sont à l'école ils vont suivre
différentes matières que ça soit
technique ou des matières générales et
du fait qu'ils soient en apprentissage
ils vont toucher un salaire tous les
mois en fonction de leur âge et de
l'année dans laquelle ils sont première
année deuxième année le salaire va
varier vous avez ici la grille donc vous
pouvez regarder ce sont des grilles
standards
et donc à la fin de leur contrats
d'apprentissage ils vont passer donc le
diplôme de fleuriste qui aujourd'hui un
diplôme national qui se déroule entre le
mois de Mars et de juin et une fois donc
leur CAP obtenu ils vont pouvoir se
lancer à la recherche d'un emploi ou
continuer leur formation dans les
niveaux supérieurs de fleuristerie
alors je vous avais vu il y a un petit
quiz qui est apparu la question c'est en
signant à comprendre un contrat
d'apprentissage est-ce que je deviens
salarié de l'entreprise vrai ou faux et
bien vous avez trouvé pour 66 % des
réponses oui
le jeune qui rentre dans l'entreprise
devient salarié de l'entreprise
au même titre que n'importe quel autre
salarié
bravo vous avez gagné
et donc est-ce que vous pouvez revenir
ça va slide Léa merci donc j'en profite
là parce qu'il y a la grille il y a la
grille des salaires alors autour de moi
on en a deux apprentis tu es majeur toi
tu te situes dans la grille là quel est
du couteau
21-25 ans donc à cet âge-là le salaire
qui est un salaire net abrupte de toute
façon il y a pas de cotisations sociales
sur les salaires on est d'accord
il n'y a pas de cotisations sociales sur
les salaires donc tu gagnes
989 euros à peu près toi Alicia tu te
trouves dans la grille de 18 ans à 20
ans 18 ans 20 ans et donc ton salaire et
c'est le salaire pour tous les c'est la
même grille pour tous les apprentis donc
il y a pas d'histoire de chimieux pays
pas mieux payés 721 euros par mois ce
qui est quand même
une belle petite somme quand on apprend
un métier et qu'on travaille je pense
enfin la moitié du temps dans
l'entreprise merci Léa
alors on va on va passer là une petite
vidéo du lieu de formation des apprentis
d'Auteuil où vous allez pouvoir
découvrir et le lieu et le témoignage
d'un certain nombre d'apprentis
professeurs
le CAP Fleuriste c'est un sapé qui
permet de devenir artisan
fleur et qui se fait soit en deux ans
soit en un an donc deux ans quand on
sort de la troisième ou qu'on n'a pas de
diplôme supérieur au relevé et un an
pour des adultes par exemple qui
auraient déjà le niveau du bac
[Musique]
création manipuler les fleurs énormément
c'est un peu tout nouveau pour moi mais
finalement je sens que j'ai choisi la
bonne vibration
à peu près une semaine
après on a soit 2 semaines en entreprise
ou soit 3 semaines en entreprise une
journée de pratique par semaine et le
reste ce sera des cours en connaissance
de végétaux
en tout ce qui est tout ce qui tourne en
fait au couteau de la fleur de son
scientifiquement
peut apprendre énormément en boutique
aussi
dans le dur finalement parce que on est
on est un peu libre à nous-mêmes notre
supérieur derrière
et ça me dépays énormément parce que
vraiment sympa c'est tout un énorme
campus
la nature nous entoure et ça fait du
bien déjà de se sentir ici on apprend
bien
on a pas mal d'intervenants extérieurs
qui peuvent venir par exemple animer des
ateliers créatifs de poterie d'art
floral japonais qui est banal et on
essaye d'organiser aussi souvent
possible des sorties dans des lieux par
exemple comme des parcs des châteaux
pour découvrir la boutique toute la
botanique
qui va se dérouler en deux ans
[Musique]
plus riche en public donc traditionnelle
d'autres vont aller plutôt travailler en
jardinerie on a aussi des élèves qui eux
sont allés travailler à Rungis au niveau
des fournisseurs de fleurs mais aussi
des jeunes qui montrent leurs propres
entreprises pour devenir par exemple
Welling planner organiser des mariages
et puis après pour ouvrir peut-être ma
boutique si un jour j'ai envie de
l'ouvrir
bien alors moi je vais vous parler plus
en détail du campus Saint-Antoine donc
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un établissement de la Fondation
apprenti d'Auteuil nous sommes implantés
sur un parc de 14 hectares depuis plus
de 80 ans alors je l'ai pas précisé au
tout début mais la Fondation apprentie
d'Auteuil c'est une fondation qui existe
depuis plus de 155 ans et au sein de
notre site de Marcoussis on a un lycée
et unifa alors une IFA c'est une unité
de formation par apprentissage et donc à
ce titre on a aujourd'hui trois trois
formations d'apprentissage donc un
certain fleuriste un cap jardinier
paysagiste et aussi un mauvais
professionnel donc en jardinier
paysagiste également alors on propose
évidemment aux jeunes de de construire
leur avenir en formant un métier en lien
avec le paysage la nature l'horticulture
et la fleuristerie ainsi qu'aux services
aux personnes et par la voie scolaire ce
qu'on appelle la formation initiale ou
la voie de l'apprentissage on accueille
aujourd'hui une soixantaine d'apprentis
sur notre site et on a aussi
parallèlement à ça un dispositif de
préparantage propulse qui est également
un sas de soutien à la recherche de
contrat d'apprentissage en amont voire
même en aval de l'apprentissage
du coup le métier de fleuriste on va
regarder un petit peu en détail en quoi
ça consiste c'est un métier qui permet
d'apprendre différentes choses déjà on
va apprendre à s'approvisionner donc à
bien acheter les fleurs et les plantes
et aussi à savoir les stocker donc on va
passer pas mal de temps à faire
l'arrivage des fleurs coupées à
apprendre à les mettre à l'eau à les
mettre dans une chambre climatique par
exemple c'est aussi enfin un cap dans
lequel il faut être plutôt à l'aise en
vente donc on va apprendre aux jeunes à
bien se comporter avec un client à
savoir communiquer à savoir vendre du
début jusqu'à l'encaissement mais aussi
du coup une partie très importante à
savoir créer des compositions florales
des bouquets des compositions piquées du
deuil des compositions de plantes
racinées savoir préparer des
compositions pour un mariage et
également
il faut avoir quand même certaines
compétences pour venir dans le CAP
Fleuriste je pense notamment à être
quelqu'un d'assez organisé d'être
dynamique d'avoir envie de travailler
parce que c'est un métier où on est
beaucoup debout et on est amené à
beaucoup bouger dans la journée
c'est quand même mieux d'avoir un
certain sens artistique et d'esthétique
parce que on en a besoin effectivement
pour réaliser de jolies compositions en
général les jeunes qui sont dans le cap
Fleurus sont des jeunes qui sont très
manuels qui ont envie de construire des
objets de bricoler et il faut aussi être
à l'aise pour vendre et être en relation
avec le client donc il faut plutôt ne
pas être trop timide et avoir envie
d'aller vers les autres
donc les jeunes une fois qu'ils ont le
CAP Fleuriste ils obtiennent le titre
d'Artisan Fleuriste certains peuvent
continuer vers le Brevet Professionnel
donc le BP et puis après par exemple
vers le brevet de maîtrise donc ce sont
deux autres diplômes qui se font en deux
ans et qui peuvent se faire en
alternance
en termes de travail après le CAP
Fleuriste ils peuvent devenir donc
vendeur en boutique donc vendeur c'est
pas seulement vendre c'est aussi créer
les compositions florales certains
d'entre eux peuvent même prendre des
postes de responsables de boutiques donc
beaucoup d'entre eux vont aller dans des
boutiques traditionnelles mais pas que
ils peuvent aller à travailler dans des
jardineries où il y a un petit coin
fleuristerie d'autres vont gérer
les boutiques de libre-service certains
vont travailler plus tôt en atelier
c'est un peu la nouvelle tendance pour
les mariages notamment d'autres dans des
hôtels pour la décoration pour faire de
l'événementiel ou dans des parcs
d'attraction par exemple où il y a
besoin de fleuristes
alors quel est le parcours de formation
justement le parcours de formation donc
c'est deux ans de formation sauf qu'à
particulier on en parlait tout à l'heure
un petit peu accessible dès 16 ans alors
on peut revenir sur le cas particulier
justement de Matteo
pourquoi lui il fait censé AP en un an
donc du coup certains jeunes viennent en
CAP Fleuriste plutôt pour faire une
sorte de reconversion professionnelle
ils sont déjà passés par différentes
étapes notamment par le baccalauréat ou
par l'obtention de notre cap on a
certains jeunes qui ont fait des CAP
horticole et qui viennent après en
fleuristerie qui est une suite assez
logique du coup ces jeunes là n'auront
pas à passer toutes les matières du Cap
ils vont passer uniquement les matières
techniques exactement et du coup ne
suivront pas les cours de français de
maths d'anglais et ils peuvent du coup
faire le cap en un donc Matteo tout à
l'heure on a dit que tu avais toi aussi
un parcours un peu particulier tu peux
nous expliquer ce que tu as
avant de faire un CAP en un an
en général et après j'ai commencé un peu
des études dans le tourisme mais bon ça
va pas forcément plus et qu'est-ce qui
t'a amené justement à faire de la fleur
de la fleur c'est un peu un coup de tête
finalement
c'est aussi en aidant un peu ma mère
dans son jardin pour tout ce qui est
jardinage et aussi mon côté des
recherches que j'ai fait en amont et
j'ai trouvé le campus de ma propulsif et
ensuite j'ai fait quelques rendez-vous
je me suis un peu plus documenté et
renseigné et puis
pour le coup là ça fait un bac général
j'ai peut-être fait une première année
de BTS tourisme mais tu avais envie
d'être manuel au fond
bien un peu dessiné qui a ce genre de
choses par exemple j'aime le dessin
j'aime j'aime peindre un petit peu quand
j'ai du temps libre pas forcément tout
le temps mais ouais il y avait un peu de
tout ça et ça s'est mélangé avec un
nouveau plan un goût à la nature la
nature là ça c'est
et toi Alicia tu donc toi aussi tu fais
un CAP en un an
qu'est-ce que tu avais fait auparavant
on est dans la personne donc soit en
école ça avec les personnes âgées
d'accord et tu as obtenu ton cap sauf
que bah c'était pas vraiment mon domaine
à moi j'ai pas eu le choix de le faire
et
mais après on m'a parlé de fleuriste
soit les animaux soient fleuristes mais
les animaux c'est un peu plus compliqué
niveau soin et je peux pas du coup j'ai
été en fleuriste parce que bah j'ai un
côté très créatif très manuel assez
autonome et je sais aussi travailler en
équipe donc du coup tu t'es dit
travailler les fleurs travailler tout ça
c'est ça que je veux faire oui c'est ça
OK et il y a la suite de ça cap tu vas
continuer tu penses que en BP et toi
Mathéo
très bien merci
et nous voilà voilà donc 13 semaines
donc par an ensemble de formation et 34
semaines par an en entreprise donc en
effet vous voyez que la partie
entreprise elle est très importante et
c'est le cas nous fait de
l'apprentissage alors on a évidemment un
enseignement général que vous connaissez
tous le français les maths les sciences
éco l'histoire-géo et l'EPS et aussi on
a un enseignement Virginie professionnel
donc l'enseignement professionnel en
gros il se regroupe sur deux jours et
demi par semaine passée au lycée
vous avez une journée intégralement
dédiée au TP donc vraiment où on va
pratiquer la fleur coupée et l'épée ces
travaux pratiques voilà une journée de
travaux pratiques où on va pratiquer
donc la fleur coupée où on apprend
souvent à faire des pièces que vous
ferez pas en boutique faute de temps
mais également on essaye de capitaliser
sur ce qui a été appréhend boutique pour
apprendre à faire des bouquets par
exemple et ensuite donc il y a d'autres
matières comme la BI il faut aussi
passer par la reconnaissance des
végétaux savoir reconnaître les fleurs
qui sont en boutique on a des cours de
vente des cours de dessin tout ce qui
est également on appelle ça technologie
professionnelle c'est l'apprentissage du
métier par le vocabulaire le nom des
pièces de fleuristerie
le nom du matériel etc etc
voilà peut-être pour associer à ça en
effet on participe dans certains cas des
concours professionnels comme le MAAF
encore ainsi
meilleure apprenti de France
c'est l'équivalent des meufs meilleur
ouvrier de France mais appliqué aux
apprentis voilà chaque année les jeunes
qui ont envie de s'inscrire et qui sont
en deuxième année peuvent s'inscrire
donc il y a plusieurs niveaux d'abord on
passe le niveau départemental puis
régional puis nationale donc les jeunes
depuis plusieurs années s'inscrivent on
a eu déjà plusieurs médailles d'ailleurs
à ce concours et puis on essaye
également de participer à d'autres
concours comme des concours d'emballage
voilà
voilà donc et puis à l'issue de la
formation un examen final et en effet
encore le cap donc c'est-à-dire
d'aptitude professionnelle et délivrée
et dans ce cadre là par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale alors ce qui est
important pour nous ce que nous notre
notre campus c'est régi par le mystère
de l'agriculture c'était cette formation
d'accord je peux vous demander quel est
le taux de réussite au cap dans
CAP Fleuriste il est aux alentours de
80% pour l'année dernière
ça varie entre 80 et 100% d'accord
alors si jamais vous êtes intéressé par
ce qu'on vient de vous dire et par cette
formation de taper fleuriste il y a
plusieurs choses il y a une première
étape que sont les portes ouvertes donc
là vous avez la liste de nos 11 portes
ouvertes à venir alors pour s'inscrire
une porte ouverte évidemment il faut il
faut nous appeler il faut appeler notre
secrétariat pour pouvoir prendre
rendez-vous
les portes ouvertes ont lieu
principalement le samedi certainement
lieu le mercredi que le mercredi 15 mars
ou le 14 juin la prochaine porte ouverte
du 11 février malheureusement complète
donc ça sera celle du 11 mars entre 9h30
et 12h30 allez partenaires sont
extrêmement importantes parce qu'elles
permettent surtout de visiter notre site
de venir voir en effet notre campus
de pouvoir avoir un effet des salles de
voir en effet à l'intérieur donc ça là
tout ce qu'on vous dit aujourd'hui c'est
très intéressant important mais
cependant c'est encore plus important de
venir nous voir et d'aller en effet voir
notre campus deuxième étape c'est en
effet de faire des ministages sur des
plateaux techniques de faire aussi des
des tests et enfin dernière étape
trouver un maître d'apprentissage parce
que il n'y a pas d'apprentissage sans
mettre d'apprentissage et de formation
et donc avec en effet un CV lettre de
motivation le sourire parce que c'est
toujours important et surtout de la
pugnacité
ok donc je vous invite vraiment si vous
êtes
là vous êtes en troisième donc en phase
de d'orientation qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire l'année prochaine continuer
à dans le cursus général ou pas en
fonction que vous appétences et de votre
situation aussi personnelle donc
n'hésitez surtout pas à aller dans les
portes ouvertes c'est le moment où
jamais où on voit les lieux dans
lesquels on va être formés ou on
s'imprègne de de ce qui se fait et
surtout on discute avec les professeurs
et les élèves qui sont présents et donc
c'est un moment très riche et si vous
avez des doutes quant à votre
orientation n'hésitez pas à faire les
portes ouvertes de la fleuristerie du
bâtiment pour pour faire le bon choix
c'est le moment de faire le bon choix
dans dans sa vie c'est tôt je sais vous
êtes jeune mais c'est écrit c'est pour
tout le monde pareil on est tous passé
par là et c'est vraiment un moment
crucial et clé pour votre avenir vous
pouvez vous tromper on a eu l'exemple on
peut toujours revenir en arrière
mais autant voilà se donner le maximum
de chances tout de suite alors vous avez
vu apparaître
sur l'écran un quiz la question était
combien d'apprentis deviennent chefs
d'entreprise après leurs études donc je
pense l'avoir cité dans le propos
d'introduction c'est 50%
un
apprenti sur deux deviendra chef
d'entreprise artisanale ouvrira sa
boutique
voilà donc c'est la proportion est quand
même assez énorme ça veut dire que
l'apprentissage c'est vraiment ça fait
partie de l'artisanat alors c'est la
transmission du savoir du maître
d'apprentissage à l'apprenti et ainsi de
suite et c'est comme ça qu'on apprend le
métier et c'est comme ça que les métiers
perdurent depuis des centaines des
milliers d'années il y a 250 métiers
dans l'artisanat et c'est 250 métiers
pour la plupart sont appris par la voie
de l'apprentissage et transmis de pairs
en pair en pair voilà
juste que je voulais rajouter ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ce qui est
important c'est que si jamais vous avez
un une envie de ce métier et c'est pour
le tester ce qui est intéressant chez
nous c'est ça c'est de pouvoir aller
pratiquer dans le cas de ces ministères
on vous accueillera évidemment avec
grand plaisir et c'est la meilleure
façon surtout ces métiers qui sont
manuels même si on a de très belles
présentations aujourd'hui mais cependant
d'aller la voir en vrai c'est très
important pour pouvoir justement tester
voir en effet si c'est vraiment
à ce qu'on veut faire parce que on peut
très bien être écœuré par l'odeur des
fleurs ce qui est rare
mais imaginons qu'on est
un olfactif très très poussé et que
finalement bon on peut très bien avoir
développé je sais pas moi des allergies
des choses comme ça donc le tester ou se
dire bah non c'est pas ça que je veux
faire quoi et donc hop changer de voix
et ou alors être subjugué par par ce
moment test là
ok je vais laisser la parole à Cécile
qui va nous donner les trois principaux
conseils pour voilà bien faire son
apprentissage Cécile et médiatrice de
l'apprentissage à la Chambre de métiers
d'artisanat de l'Essonne donc elle a une
expérience entre elle met en relation et
elle gère des éventuels conflits entre
l'apprenti et le salarié et à la trois
conseils à vous donner Cécile c'est à
toi merci bonjour à tous
alors je vais oui essayer de pas mon
expérience
de vous donner du coup trois conseils
pour bien enclencher
votre apprentissage à mon sens avec
l'expérience que j'ai donc en un montrez
sa motivation alors effectivement a
priori c'est juste du bon sens mais
effectivement c'est c'est très important
ça englobe beaucoup de choses ne
serait-ce que par exemple arriver à
l'heure comme je dis toujours vous vous
faites partie de l'apprenti de
excusez-moi je suis fatiguée
vous faites partie de l'entreprise d'une
équipe donc chaque minute compte les
gens ne vont pas vous attendre donc
c'est vrai que c'est important d'être
à l'heure et ça fait partie
de bien montrer sa motivation son envie
de bien faire et tout ça donc ça
vraiment j'insiste là dessus c'est très
important et encore une fois vous êtes
payé donc je sais que ça souvent ça fait
la différence et ça vous aide à bien
comprendre le pourquoi du comment
n'hésitez pas aussi à réclamer une autre
tâche éventuellement quand on vous donne
une tâche et que vous l'avez fini
que vous avez pas trop quoi faire que
c'est les débuts voilà vous êtes timide
je ça on conçoit tout ce que c'est pas
facile d'aller voir son maître
d'apprentissage et lui demander de lui
demander une autre tâche et tout ça mais
surtout voilà
faites-vous violence c'est quelque chose
qui sera toujours très apprécié on
pourra on pourra jamais vous le
reprocher en tout cas en entreprise donc
vraiment tout ça ce sont des petites
choses qui montrent la motivation en
tout cas l'envie de faire et de et de
mieux faire le deuxième point c'est se
passer de son téléphone portable alors
ça c'est un point qui est clé et qui est
très très récurrent sur sur tous les
conflits que je peux avoir honnêtement
voilà c'est quelque chose qui revient
très très souvent donc on comprend bien
que c'est c'est votre troisième main que
c'est quelque chose vous êtes juste né
avec donc c'est normal mais voilà il
faut vraiment faire un effort là-dessus
comme au même titre que à l'école bien
essayé de faire de faire attention à ça
en entreprise alors déjà dans un premier
temps parce que vous allez apprendre un
nouveau métier un métier et que du coup
il faut toute votre attention
aussi pour pas vous blesser enfin je
veux dire là on est dans la fleuristerie
mais effectivement dans beaucoup de
métiers de l'artisanat c'est c'est le
cas que ce soit l'hygiène que ce soit
que ce soit aussi la dangerosité
vraiment faut faire attention à ça donc
voilà éviter juste les TikTok et les
snapchat sur le lieu de travail ça
serait pas mal
vous avez des pauses vous vous allez
pouvoir récupérer votre téléphone
portable sans problème et voilà c'est
vraiment un point où il faudra il faudra
faire attention là-dessus
et le troisième point c'est solliciter
des échanges avec son mode son maître
d'apprentissage alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire en fait moi ce que je vois
dans les litiges dans certains conflits
c'est effectivement le manque de
communication
90% du temps ça va être ça va être
clairement ce genre de problème qui
revient aussi on ne prend pas le temps
de se parler donc moi ce que je donne
comme conseil clé c'est vraiment dès le
départ de votre contrat d'apprentissage
vraiment les premiers les premières
semaines tout de suite mettre en place
effectivement ce temps
de discussion avec votre maître
d'apprentissage même si c'est 5 minutes
on demande pas une demi-heure on sait
que les mettre en apprentissage et les
entreprises dans le concret ont beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à faire et n'auront
pas forcément le temps de vous accorder
beaucoup de minutes donc si déjà 5
minutes par exemple vous avez une
semaine entreprise une semaine école ce
que je conseille de faire c'est que
avant de retourner à l'école le jeudi ou
le vendredi de faire un point même 5
minutes encore une fois pour dire voilà
qu'est-ce qui va qu'est-ce qui va pas
sur quoi je dois m'améliorer sur quoi
voilà et ça je pense que ça mettra en
place
un échange une confiance et
une proximité de pouvoir se parler si
jamais il y a un jour il y a quelque
chose qui ne qui ne va pas et de mieux
vous connaître et vraiment la discussion
et surtout de de se dire les choses même
quand ça va pas et de pas engendrer
ensuite des conflits beaucoup plus
compliqué ensuite à gérer voilà ce sont
les trois les trois points qui me
paraissent importants merci merci de ton
intervention donc c'est vraiment des
points qui ont été relevés par Cécile et
qui sont le témoignage des entretiens
qu'elle a avec et les apprentis et les
chefs d'entreprise puisqu'ils c'est son
rôle et donc c'est pas sorti de notre
chapeau c'est vraiment le témoignage de
voilà de ce qu'il faut retenir montrez
sa motivation se passer de son téléphone
et solliciter des échanges du feedback
sur ce que vous faites en entreprise
voilà
ensuite
alors pour venir nous voir
nous sommes situés donc évidemment à
Marcoussis marque aussi qui est connu
pour
découvrir et les nourrir de fait
exactement exactement
de
l'autre alors justement vous parlez de
du genre moi j'ai une question est-ce
que c'est des métiers les métiers la
fleuristerie j'englobe tout
fleuriste paysagiste qui concerne
davantage les hommes qui sont qui
regroupent davantage d'hommes ou
davantage de femmes ou la proportion
elle est quasi égale en fleuristerie
nous ça dépend un peu des années il y a
des années où c'est plutôt féminin et
puis là depuis plusieurs années c'est
plutôt mélangé c'est peut-être pas
moitié-moitié mais 30% de garçons et
puis le reste on peut pas dire que ce
soit un métier féminin à 100% et et dans
les métiers de du paysagisme dans le
métier du paysage on a quand même
beaucoup de garçons
[Musique]
peut s'inverser et on a de plus en plus
de films
propres à la nature et puis ça suscite
un engouement important donc on peut
considérer là aujourd'hui que on parle
plus de métiers de plein de métier
d'hommes ça a plus de sens j'ai tout à
l'heure j'étais sur le
webinaire automobile il y a des filles
aussi qui font de la carrosserie qui
font de la mécanique et ben il y a des
garçons comme Matteo qui se ronflent
fleurissent ou décorateurs à la florale
et donc il y a pas de tabou quoi enfin
surtout les meilleurs ouvriers de France
en général on fleuristerie c'est des
hommes la plupart les meilleurs ouvriers
de France là si on est au sur le top le
top level et ce sont des des hommes
comment juste avoir
souvent quand on est garçon en boutique
voilà on nous demande souvent un petit
peu plus de temps en temps de porter
combien des choses à faire des charges
un peu plus loin voilà par exemple j'ai
vendu beaucoup de savants pour ma part
moi de décembre je fais pratiquement que
ça mais c'était génial c'est une superbe
Alicia j'ai une question pour vous
quels sont pour vous les trois qualités
pour être fleuriste
je dirais créatif
souriante alors donc du coup aimable
quoi d'une manière générale avoir le
sens du commerce
[Musique]
d'accord donc faut pas être super
réservé ça va un petit peu avec le sens
du commerce pour avoir le sens du
commerce il faut être un petit peu pas
trop extraverti mais voilà aller vers
l'autre aller vers le client le
renseigner parce que il y a il y a de la
vente dans le métier
voilà
pour toi est-ce que tu as quelque chose
à compléter Matteo par rapport aux trois
qualités
osées pour cette formation je sais que
moi c'était pas du tout mon truc mais il
faut y aller en fait il faut tester en
fait vous avez le temps vous êtes jeune
je sais que là on s'adresse à un public
assez jeune par rapport à moi ou
quelques années de monde mais essayez
voilà ça vaut le coup d'essayer même si
ça vous plaît pas au moins vous me direz
ouais bah j'ai essayé et puis ça m'a pas
plu j'ai été courageux je l'ai fait
voilà essayer franchement j'ai essayé et
moi ça m'a plu et je sais que je
pourrais le recommander à d'autres
personnes et que voilà et c'est tout
d'accord merci Matteo
bon là on est on a fini la phase de
présentation j'ai vu dans le chat qu'il
y a eu des connexions un petit peu
tardives est-ce que vous avez eu des
soucis connexion ou peut-être mal noté
l'horaire je vous rassure si vous avez
pas suivi la première partie du
webinaire ce webinaire est enregistré et
vous le retrouverez sur le site de la
Chambre de métier d'artisanat Essonne
c'est moi CMA
essonne.fr ou vous avez
l'enregistrement des cinq conférences
qui auront lieu aujourd'hui sur les
thématiques dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure automobile bâtiment fleuristerie
goût quand je dis goût il y a de la
boulangerie il y a de la restauration et
beauté et dans la beauté c'est
esthétisme et coiffure donc ne vous
inquiétez pas si vous avez loupé le
début vous pourrez rattraper en
visionnant les la première minute donc
là je vous invite à poser toutes les
questions que vous souhaitez j'en ai des
enfin là on a déjà relevé
plusieurs alors pour la question quel
est le salaire moyen d'un fleuriste
alors le salaire moyen d'un fleuriste en
boutique en boutique donc en tant que
salarié oui ok alors du coup ben c'est
pareil que pour l'apprentissage il y a
une grille bien définie dans la
convention collective avec des salaires
qui varient en fonction de deux choses
d'abord du diplôme obtenu quelqu'un qui
a le cap n'aura pas le même salaire que
quelqu'un qui a un BP donc un brevet de
professionnel ou un brevet de maîtrise
donc plus on fait des études plus on va
avoir un bon salaire ça ça c'est un peu
la généralité de tous les métiers et la
deuxième chose c'est l'expérience bien
sûr donc on évolue au fil du temps
quelqu'un qui sort d'un CAP fleuriste et
qui n'a aucune expérience va toucher le
SMIC en gros et cela ne comprend pas
bien sûr les heures supplémentaires les
primes que peut donner le patron mais ça
c'est la convention collective il y a
beaucoup de d'employés d'employeurs qui
ne se basent pas forcément sur ça et qui
vont aussi proposer un salaire un petit
peu supérieur quand on dit conventions
collectives c'est le salaire minimum
et il faut savoir quand même en
fleuristerie il y a quand même pas mal
d'heures supplémentaires en fonction des
saisons notamment pour les fêtes pour la
Saint-Valentin qui va avec des mères
voilà du coup bah les salaires sont
assez variable et sont rarement
finalement proche du SMIC donc alors on
peut dire qu'on est plutôt vers
200-300 euros au dessus du SMIC voilà
sauf quand on débute évidemment faut
quand même après quelqu'un qui a un bébé
de l'expérience peut arriver à 2000
euros net
c'est pas mal
autre question
faut-il avoir un bon bulletin de notes
pour intégrer la formation
alors j'ai vu tout à l'heure dans le
chat je suis nul en mal je suis nul en
science alors déjà on dit pas je suis
nul voilà ça c'est non vous n'êtes pas
hyper bon c'est pas votre matière
privilégiée mais vous êtes certainement
bon dans d'autres matières donc faut-il
avoir un bon bulletin de notes pour
intégrer la formation alors nous dans la
formation quand on sort de troisième on
a des jeunes qui ont pu avoir le brevet
et il y en a d'autres qui n'ont pas le
brevet donc avoir son brevet des
collèges n'est déjà pas une obligation
pour intégrer le cap je vous incite à
l'avoir c'est quand même mieux
après ce qu'on va enfin là où on va
trouver de l'importance et surtout sur
cette journée de test comment ça s'est
passé durant la journée de test au lycée
moi il y a des élèves qui viennent dans
cette journée de test et qui me disent
qu'ils sont nuls en maths nul en
français mais ça n'empêche pas qu'ils
ont des compétences techniques qui vont
finalement être parfaite pour intégrer
un CAP fleuriste et puis bon après les
matières générales nous on a de la
chance d'avoir des places de petites
classes du coup les professeurs prennent
du temps pour revoir les notions de base
quel est le pourcentage de matière
générale je parle pas des du Cap
le pourcentage entre matières générales
et matière dites un peu plus
professionnel technique en gros on a
deux jours et demi voire trois jours de
matière technique et deux jours de
matière générale qui comprennent
également le sport ouais d'accord il y a
du dessin oui
ça fait partie des matières techniques
d'accord donc on peut dire un tiers de
tiers à peu près
ce qu'on peut rajouter c'est ce qui est
important avant toute chose c'est comme
la motivation c'est qu'en effet on va
étudier chaque cas et ça c'est vraiment
important
l'important si vous voulez vraiment être
fleuriste c'est de venir nous voir et en
effet là on étudie voilà on laisse pas
les gens sur le bord de la route on
laisse pas les gens sur le bord de la
route ça pourra être le slogan
d'Apprentis d'Auteuil c'est pas vraiment
nos sons c'est la confiance peut sauver
l'avenir on n'était pas loin OK
[Musique]
alors autre question donc j'ai répondu
en arrêt pour vous avez répondu aux
questions générales ah je peux vous
demander
quel est votre moyenne actuellement en
CAP là je pense que le bulletin il est
tombé là
j'essaie mais disons que j'aurais pu
avoir mieux mais en fait il faut être
motivé aussi parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un peu long c'est un risque qui
est assez compliqué à faire entreprise
c'est moins que que si on avait des
études dans le scolaire scolaire mais il
y a un petit peu travaillé comme un
fournir mais on oublie en fait on oublie
parce qu'on travaille puisqu'on est pris
dedans et que et que ça nous passionne
mais ouais il y a combien d'heures de
cours dans la semaine quand tu es à
l'école 35 35 comme en entreprise ok
d'accord Alicia je peux te demander ta
moyenne je vais pas faire de gaffe j'ai
13 de moyenne en ce moment
j'aurais pu avoir mis aussi mais moi
c'est la biologie je bloque avec la
biologie il y a de la biologie oui mais
c'est de biologie appliquée à la fleur
ouais d'accord
c'est pas pénalisant ça t'empêchera pas
d'avoir ça voilà
[Musique]
alors autre question
peut-on intégrer la formation CAP à
l'âge de 40 ans mais il y a des élèves
la con Carentan derrière où c'est une
prof c'est une question d'un professeur
ça merci le professeur d'avoir posé
cette question parce que ça peut ça
intéresse les gens qui sont en
conversion professionnelle et il y a pas
vraiment d'âge pour faire un CAP de
manière générale non il y a pas d'âge
après ce qui va changer c'est plutôt la
manière de le mettre en application
parce qu'on peut pas être apprenti à 40
ans bah non il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui se reconvertissent qui suivent les
cours et qui en parallèle vont faire des
stages en boutique donc là ça sera
plutôt des stages qui pour enfin pour la
plupart vont être garantis par Pôle
emploi
donc qui vont leur permettre d'avoir une
convention de stage d'accord ok je vois
une question là nous avons des
stagiaires étrangers
quel est le niveau de français de
demander pour le CAP Fleuriste alors des
alors faudrait savoir quel est le niveau
de leur de français à l'oral au moins
nous on a des étudiants étrangers vous
en avez déjà on en a déjà leur niveau de
français à l'oral et correct qui leur
permet d'intégrer facilement une
entreprise mais également au fur et à
mesure de communiquer avec le client
les cris c'est pas forcément tout de
suite un niveau
un niveau qui est demandé pour le cap
mais en deux ans ils ont le temps de de
s'améliorer il y a français il y a la
matière française combien d'heures
combien deux à trois heures deux à trois
heures deux à trois heures de français
et puis après on sait mettre en place
aussi des spéci
d'accord ce type de personne donc c'est
pas un frein à l'inscription non c'est
pareil on va évaluer ça par rapport à la
journée de stage voir la motivation du
jeûne on a des jeunes qui sont arrivés
qui n'étaient pas capables vraiment
d'écrire et qui ont eu leur CAP avec
succès voilà
oui voilà puis après peut-être rajouter
qu'on a aussi d'autres d'autres
formations
en effet le niveau de français n'est pas
forcément
[Musique]
importantes professionnelles qu'on met
en place pour les adultes correspondrait
bien à ça et on a des là on a un ouvrier
du paysage technique commence au mois de
mars c'est des choses qui veulent se
mettre aussi en place accessoire alors
vous vous entendez beaucoup en ce moment
parler de de métier en tension de
secteur en tension on pense notamment au
bâtiment à la restauration et qui manque
qui manque de professionnels du bâtiment
et de la restauration est-ce que c'est
le cas dans le secteur de la fleur
historique alors les chez les fleuristes
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à recruter on
a du mal à recruter notamment aussi en
Essonne parce que pour plusieurs raisons
c'est que bah voilà il on en manque de
manque de fleuriste de fleuriste on est
obligé parfois d'embaucher des gens qui
qui n'ont pas de cap pour nous aider sur
sur l'entretien de la boutique sur des
tâches à moindre valeur que celle de
fleuriste ce qui permet de libérer le
seul peut-être salarié sur la fonction
plus technique exactement d'accord donc
ça veut dire que quand on fait un CAP
fleuriste et qu'on est voilà on a le
goût pour le faire Alicia vous allez
trouver un job à l'issue d'autres
formations normalement il y a pas de
souci et vous vous iriez plutôt en
boutique vous mais vous avez dit ou pas
est-ce que vous aimeriez vendre en
boutique ou plutôt faire de
l'événementiel en boutique Mathéo c'est
ton cas aussi
ce que je fais déjà parce que ce qui est
bien parce qu'on peut toucher à tout
quand on a de la chance de tomber dans
une bonne boutique mais oui plus de plus
en boutique
on sait que c'est des métiers pour
lesquels on aura si on est voilà on a un
job
si on est présentable si on est avenant
et si on est un bon technicien on aura
un job c'est sûr voilà un job
au départ rémuné à hauteur du SMIC au
minimum mettez-vous à évoluer quoi voilà
exactement donc pas beaucoup plus bas
qu'une infirmière qui a fait trois
années d'études après le bac je pense à
elle mais donc ça veut dire que
passer un job qui est pas mal rémunéré
alors évidemment on va travailler
peut-être les week-end oui effectivement
et encore ça dépend à des entreprises
souvent les entreprises ils font des
efforts pour laisser de week-end par
mois aux employés donc on travaille de
week-end et on a deux weekends c'est
nouveau parce que il y a quelques années
c'était tous les week-ends
et puis il y a des périodes qui sont
plus creuses sur lequel on va on va
avoir moins de travail mais
alors est-ce que il y a d'autres
questions non pas d'autres questions moi
j'en ai une est-ce que ça arrive en
boutique que des clients laisse un petit
pourboire à celui qui a fait un beau
petit bouquet une belle composition
est-ce que c'est une pratique courante
pas
en tout cas sur Paris oui sur Paris oui
sur Paris oui enfin moi je faisais des
livraisons à pied ou en métro et la
plupart du temps me donner des
pourboires
si on fait bien son job si on me
présente bien si on est gentil les gens
ils hésitent pas d'accord
donc c'est j'allais dire faut pas
compter dessus mais c'est un complément
quoi qui permet de mettre un peu de
beurre dans les épinards
je vous invite à poser les dernières
questions parce qu'on arrive au bout de
notre webinaire donc c'est le l'occasion
ou jamais de voilà de poser vos
questions aux apprentis et
aux professionnels de la filière qui
sont à Virginie et Dominique donc je
vous laisse un petit temps pour essayer
de poser des questions sinon bah on
clôturera
ah moi j'ai une question entre pendant
que vous réfléchissez
dans la dans la salle là derrière
l'écran vous êtes des classes est-ce que
les professeurs peuvent faire un petit
sondage pour savoir qui là au regard de
notre web conférence est intéressé pour
elle éventuellement se diriger
vers la fleuristerie qui est-ce que ça
sent bien sensibilise est-ce que vous
pouvez faire un petit sondage ouais moi
ça m'intéresserait ou ça m'intéresserait
pas et nous donner voilà deux trois deux
trois éléments sur le chat
je vous fais travailler
bien bien bien
j'attends un peu parce que il y a un
petit temps de latence entre le moment
où je parle ou le moment où vous recevez
[Musique]
non
France compétence Antony lui stagiaires
sur 30 serait intéressé par par cette
filière c'est une très très belle
proportion
[Musique]
merci France compétence à Anthony j'aime
beaucoup cette ville
bon pas d'autre réponse pas de réponse
tant pis en tout cas merci d'avoir
participé à ce webinaire merci pour vos
questions merci à Dominique Alicia
Virginie et Matteo d'être à mes côtés et
je vous souhaite une belle journée et
surtout une belle orientation et faites
le bon choix
choisissez l'artisanat
allez au revoir